[Music]
um
[Music]
hey what's up guys i'm kphd here and
they did it these are the colorware
airpods
and this is dope tech so i've showed
colorware stuff before you remember
they've painted laptops you know
headphones controllers all kinds of
stuff by taking it apart repainting it
and then putting it back together it's
awesome so these air pods have proven to
be one of the most difficult things to
map and paint and everything because of
their curvy shape and their tiny size
and just overall tons of miniature
details but better late than never you
gotta trust the process and now you're
looking at the first fully functioning
matte air pods on the planet and yes i
went with the crazy red in one ear and
black in the other ear because well i
wanted to know what they both look like
and i think the matte formula red looks
great in the hand and just while
examining it you can see all the little
sensors and the earpiece and the
microphone holes and all the little
things that the paint around and they've
done it all seemingly perfectly no
chipping no paint that's thicker in some
places and thinner and others it's a
perfectly uniform satin coat that gives
it that undercover matte look that beats
the regular glossy white air pods every
day in my opinion now there's another
company slick wraps that's doing skins
for the airpods and i'm sure that's
pretty cool and it looks probably great
when it's done well but to me skins
don't quite seem like the ideal way to
do it the application process first of
all to get it perfectly around the
earpod is probably insanely hard it
would definitely also add thickness to
the buds and most importantly the edges
would stick up from the edges of the
airpod and be uncomfortable and probably
catch your skin and even scratch you so
the way to go is definitely paint and if
you ask me the matte black is the goat
now it'll definitely be harder to find
if you drop them i'll definitely give
you that that's true but they look a lot
less noticeable in your ears which is
kind of the point they don't scream
steal me as much and if earpods and
airpods do fit in your ears then you can
wear them and they'll feel and look a
lot like just any other regular black
pair of wireless headphones out there
and that's the idea all the
functionality still works and the
features are still there you know double
tap for siri and volume control and next
track and everything it's not my
favorite way to control any wireless
earbuds like i mentioned in the review
but hey it still works perfectly which
is what matters and as you can see they
even paint the case too which is very
cool so definitely an expensive and
premium option not so many people can
even do this with their airpods
especially when they're so rare and are
outright out of stock everywhere but
i am squarely in their target
demographic for something like this and
in case you didn't know i really am a
fan of matte black like i mentioned in
the last video the dear apple video so i
would actually get these probably to use
while i work on a matte black imac on a
matte black desk probably while
listening to panda i'd probably be
typing on a matte black apple keyboard
with a matte black apple mouse to go
with it
but then that would probably get old
kind of quick so i'd bring in a matte
black mx master and then the keyboard
would get old too so i'd bring in yeah
an all black full-on mechanical keyboard
that's right you're not seeing things
don't need any glossy letters in the way
and i'd record this voiceover using a
matte black microphone to listen to on
matte black speakers storing it on map
like storage
uh but i'm not obsessed or anything
right all right okay all right so bottom
line these obviously aren't for everyone
i'm not going to sit here and tell you
to buy them but they do seem really cool
and i figured i might as well share them
with you and this also happens to be a
super exclusive because it's the first
time anyone's ever shown matte colored
air pods from colorware on video this is
the first pair they made so i hope you
enjoyed the video thank you very much
for watching for free to hit that like
button if you did and the link to check
out all the stuff i talked about i'll
also put below the like button if you
want to check out those things too but
that's been it thank you for watching
talk to you next one
peace
[Music]